Kiawah Island South Carolina 8 a.m.
biologist JC Griffin feeds his chickens
they are bait I'm trying to catch Bobcat
kittens almost ghostly Bobcats are
rarely seen and photographed JC has been
part of a two-year study developed to
learn more about these elusive cats but
it isn't easy as is frustrating to catch
raccoons frustrating because for every
hundred animals he traps there was only
one Bobcat but he has trapped and
collared enough to know that the cats
are out there and they're thriving a
close relative of the Lynx the North
American Bobcat is nocturnal solitary
the Bobcats ranged throughout North
America but largely because of habitat
destruction they have virtually
disappeared in some places Bobcats are
opportunists and will try to kill almost
any prey available the deer population
is very stable the major reason is the
Bobcats because I really do prey on the
deer hard here Island officials fear
that without the Bobcats kiowa islands
deer population would increase and so in
car accidents we want Bobcats here we
want as many Bobcats here as possible
since there's no hunting on Kiawah
Island the only way to control the deer
population is really through Bobcat
predation the town wildlife biologist is
Jim Jordan there probably more Bobcats
living in proximity to development than
we really think because they're so hard
to see typically they're very shy and
they could be living you know not far
from housing people may never know
with the help of a radio collar and
triangulation JC can determine within a
few yards the exact location of a bobcat
I didn't see him but I know he ran right
across here is a second guy just
following me Morgan is going real slow
but even with that kind of help it took
more than an hour tracking through
people's yards to catch a glimpse
finally after hours of tracking JC
flushes him out of the brush the cat
makes a brief appearance lurking near
someone's house it helps to have this
kind of predators here
I think Bobcats are one of Kayla's most
valuable assets an asset that biologists
hope will provide a natural control for
deer in other parts of the country